CALEB: All right.
Welcome everybody.
Thank you guys for coming to
another "Authors@Google" talk
with the one and only
Steve Hindy, co-founder
and president of
Brooklyn Brewery.
His new book, "The
Craft Beer Revolution,"
tells the story about how
craft brewers joined forces
to forever change the way
the world buys, enjoys,
and appreciates beer.
As one of the founding
players in the movement,
Hindy brings a true insider's
account of the personalities,
battles, and
alliances that colored
the early days of craft beer.
So now I want to read
you a paragraph that
made me actually laugh
out loud and shows
why I like the
book so much and I
think you guys should grab it.
The set up is Paul
Shipman, the co-founder
of what became Redhook, was
telling a story to Peter Krebs
for his book-- is Krebs right--
"Redhook Beer Pioneer," when
he hilariously said
this, "We inspired people
to become microbrewers,"
Shipman claimed to Krebs,
"because every home brewer
who tasted our beer thought
they could make better
beer in the bathtub.
They were thinking
that if Redhook
could be this successful with
a beer that tasted this odd,
just think of what they could
do with a good tasting beer."
So that's one of the reasons
I think you should pick it up.
If you're still
not sure, the book
has praise from the founders of
Anchor, New Belgium, Sam Adams,
Dogfish Head, Sierra
Nevada, Deschutes,
and even the CEOs of
Miller, Coors, and Heineken.
Sam Calagione, founder
of Dogfish Head
said, "Balance-- it's a
desired trait in the brewery
world, that perfectly
comforting zone
created through the
interplay of hops and barley.
Steve Hindy has found the
equivalent space as a beer
journalist/brewing
pioneer in his book,
'The Craft Beer
Revolution.'" So here he is.
Steve Hindy.
STEVE HINDY: Thank you, Caleb.
Well, great to be here,
talking about my new book,
which is actually
my second book.
The first book is
called "Beer School,"
and it tells the whole story
of the Brooklyn Brewery,
the adventures we had in
Brooklyn, the ups and downs,
things we did right,
things we screwed up.
Actually, Mayor Bloomberg
wrote a forward to that book,
and he's quite the
entrepreneur himself.
And I was very proud of that.
You may ask, who am I to
write a history of craft beer,
and that would be
a good question.
Actually, there's an epigraph
before the author's note
in the book that quotes
Winston Churchill, saying,
"History shall be kind to me,
for I intend to write it."
And that's sort of the
approach I took with the book.
A lot of it is based on
my personal experience.
I started Brooklyn
Brewery in 1988,
and I was able to kind
of watch the development
of this industry close up.
I've been involved with the
Brewers Association, our trade
association, from the
beginning, and it just
amazed me to see what was
happening with individuals
coming from all
different walks of life
with a passion for beer,
starting companies,
and then actually
coming together
through our association
to really shape
the industry that
we were involved in.
The book begins with
the ultimate pioneer
of the craft beer
revolution, which
is Fritz Maytag, the-- obviously
a scion of the Maytag washing
machine family, who bought the
Anchor Brewery in San Francisco
in 1965.
That was a failing local brewery
with a very distinctive brewing
style called-- that made a
beer called steam beer, which
is actually a beer
made with a lager yeast
but fermented at warmer
temperatures like an ale.
So Fritz kind of bought
that brewery on a whim
and set about reconstructing
it and building
one of the most
beautiful breweries,
I think, in the world and
also dedicating himself
to bringing back that all-malt
beer called Anchor Steam.
He was alone in doing
this until 1976,
when a guy named
Jack McAuliffe, who
had been a US Navy
submariner based in Scotland
and had gotten into home
brewing when he was over there.
And also, that was-- this would
have been in the mid '70s, when
the campaign for real ale
was happening in England.
And so Jack came back to
California, to Sonoma,
and cobbled together a
brewery called New Albion,
using old soda tanks, Pepsi
tanks, 55 gallon tanks,
and dairy tanks to
make this brewery.
And actually, he
had two co-founders
with him, Suzy Denison
and Jane Zimmerman,
and I interviewed
Suzy for the book.
She's 80 years old now
but had just returned
from a tour of Europe
with her niece,
and she and Jane do a lot
of traveling together.
Actually, she told me
that she and Jane did
a lot of the brewing after
New Albion got up and running,
that Jack kind of left
the brewing to them, which
is interesting if you
think about in the days
before the commercialization of
brewing, a lot of the brewing
was done in the home by women.
So I think it's interesting
that those two women were
kind of there at the foundation
of the craft beer revolution.
That project, New Albion,
was kind of doomed
from the beginning.
I mean, it was too small, and
the whole idea of craft beer
was too new at that time to
really have any kind of chance.
But they struggled along
for about six years
before the whole thing
went out of business.
It was an important
six years though,
because there were other members
of what I call the pioneer
group-- people who started
before 1984 building craft
breweries.
So Ken Grossman
from Sierra Nevada
visited Jack and the
brewery at New Albion.
Paul Shipman, the guy
who Caleb mentioned,
from Redhook-- he
came there, the guy
from Goose Island in Chicago.
People from all
over the country who
were interested in
starting breweries
came to see what was
happening at New Albion.
And a number of breweries
started up as a result of that.
I think you know Sierra Nevada.
Ken had a bicycle repair shop
and later a home brew shop
before he started Sierra
Nevada in his garage.
Ken is an amazing
engineer and tinkerer,
and to this day,
the new brewery he's
building now in North Carolina--
he's there every day, very much
involved with the
engineering of that project.
Caleb mentioned
Redhook, and there's
a great story about
Redhook in the book, which
I think describes some
of the struggle of being
a pioneer with craft beer
back in the early '80s.
Paul Shipman was
determined he was
going to do a very
original beer,
so he didn't want to buy
a brewer's yeast from any
of the companies that have yeast
libraries where you can buy
different kinds of yeast
for different styles.
He wanted an original yeast,
so he went to a chemist
at the University of Washington
and got a yeast from him
to make Redhook Ale.
I guess he agreed with
the local publican
to launch the Redhook
Ale on a certain date.
And the date came
for the launch,
and they realized that the beer
didn't really taste very good.
But they were kind of stuck,
because they had put out
in the press that they were
going to open on this date.
So they had their grand
opening with the mayor
and all dignitaries,
and they tapped
the keg, poured the
beer, and every one
took a sip and kind of
put a good face on it.
But they knew this stuff
doesn't taste good.
And it was actually left to
a reporter for the Seattle
newspaper to say what
everyone was thinking, which
is, this beer tastes
like rotten bananas.
He called it banana beer.
But they kind of soldiered on.
This was all new
territory, and who
knew what craft beer was
supposed to taste like.
So they soldiered on with
this bad tasting banana
beer for about a year,
and people bought it
because they wanted to give
a local brewer a chance.
They were thrilled
that there was
going to be a new
brewery in Seattle.
People bought the beer,
but after about a year,
word was getting
back that people
will order this in the pub,
but they'll kind of choke down
one pint and then they'll
switch to Bud, Coors, or Miller,
because they couldn't
get much beyond the pint.
And then a guy
came to Seattle who
is very important for the
craft beer revolution.
I'm sure many of
you know the name
Michael Jackson, a
British beer writer
who wrote a really important
book called "The World
Guide to Beer,"
published in 1977.
And it was really
the first ever,
I think in history,
serious history of brewing
and how the different
styles developed.
And Michael, over his
lifetime, which unfortunately
ended at age 65-- he was
also the world's authority
on single malt scotch, and
he swallowed the scotch
and the beer, so his
life ended rather early.
But Michael visited
all those breweries.
So he came to Redhook, and
he tasted the Redhook ale.
And Michael never said anything
bad about any craft brewery.
If he didn't like
the brewery, he just
wouldn't write about it.
So he tasted it,
and he said, well
this is kind of
like a Belgian beer.
And Shipman said,
exactly, Michael!
It's a Belgian style beer.
And he set about-- he changed
all the copy on the label
to say it's a
Belgian style beer,
and they changed all
their marketing materials.
And they forged ahead,
but still, no matter what
you called it, it
didn't taste good.
And then this guy,
another guy who's
really important for the
history of craft beer,
came to Seattle, a brewing
chemist named Joe Owades.
Dr. Joe Owades.
And Joe had been the technical
director at the Rheingold
Brewery in Brooklyn, and
he developed light beer.
He developed the first ever
low calorie beer in the '60s.
Unfortunately, the
marketing department
decided to call it Gablinger's,
and it totally flopped.
No one really understood
what it was all about.
And it really wasn't
until Miller Lite years
later popularized light
beer with those less filling
more flavor commercials,
which actually many
of your generation
may not remember.
Anyway, it was a while
before light beer took off.
And Joe actually advised
many other craft brewers,
but when he came to Seattle--
Joe's a very blunt guy.
German, and very
sure of himself.
So Joe tasted the Redhook
ale, and he turned to Shipman
and said, is this made for
some sort of ethnic group
here in Seattle.
And Shipman said, no, Joe.
It's our Belgian style ale.
And Owades looked at him
and said, no, it's not.
It's infected.
He said, this beer
has a bacteria in it.
So Joe gave them a
number of a yeast
to buy from the Siebel Institute
in Chicago, which Shipman did.
And then they produced a new
beer called Ballard Bitter,
and Redhook was on
their way to success.
I love that story
because I think it really
illustrates how clueless
the small brewers were back
in the day.
Joe Owades went on to create
a beer in New York City
called New Amsterdam Amber
for one of the pioneers name
Matthew Reich, who was
the first contract brewer.
Matthew brewed his beer
in upstate New York
and sold it in New York City.
Unfortunately, he couldn't wait
to open a brewery in New York
City, and he did that on
11th Avenue and 26th Street.
And if you know anything
about New York City,
particularly back
in the mid '80s,
that neighborhood was
better known for hookers
than for a brewery with
a 300 seat restaurant.
And he was out of
business within a year
after building that brewery.
But I learned a
lot from watching
what happened to
Matthew building
the brewery prematurely
in a bad spot.
And so did Jim Cook
from Sam Adams.
Jim went to school
on Matthew, as did I.
And actually Jim
ended up hiring Owades
to develop the recipe for
Sam Adams Boston Lager.
And he also ended up
hiring Matthew's brewmaster
and assistant brewmaster,
and the brewmaster
is still with Sam
Adams to this day.
And the point I'm making
is that Jim and Brooklyn
Brewery and a lot
of other breweries
started up after the
period of the pioneers,
and we learned
from the pioneers.
That was critical
to our developing
our businesses and the
beers we were selling
and how we priced those beers.
We learned so much, the
same way the later pioneers
learned from Fritz
and New Albion.
Things developed pretty
quickly in the '80s.
There were about 1,000
breweries by 1994.
I call my generation of brewers
the first generation as opposed
to the pioneers.
A lot of people look
at the '90s and believe
there was a period where
craft beer kind of crashed,
because there were a couple
of spectacular failures.
Pete's Wicked Ale, which
actually started right here
in Palo Alto, went up
quickly to 400,000 barrels
and down almost as
quickly when they
sold to Gambrinas Company,
the importer of Corona beer.
And Catamount, in Vermont, one
of the pioneering breweries,
built a second brewery
but then stopped growing.
So one thing you
learn in manufacturing
is if you build a brewery,
you must pay for that brewery.
And if you don't produce
beer in that brewery,
you're probably not going to
be able to pay for the brewery.
And I've seen that
happen numerous times
to different people.
But in writing the book,
one thing I realized
is that, far from a
slump in the '90s,
there were actually about
500 breweries started up
between '94 and 2000, including
some incredibly innovative
breweries, like Dogfish
in Delaware, Allagash,
up in Maine, Russian
River, here in California,
New Belgium in Colorado.
And the difference
between those breweries
and Brooklyn and
the first generation
was that they were making
Belgian style beers.
First generation, we
were kind of stuck
on the idea of the
German purity law,
making beer according
to the Reinheitsgebot,
using only the four basic
ingredients of beer.
But these breweries that
started up in the '90s
made all different
kinds of styles
based on the Belgian styles,
and Sam Calagione, in Delaware,
will put chocolate
mole in his beer.
So far from being a
slump, it was actually
a whole new-- a whole new
push toward innovation
in the craft beer movement.
The last 10 years have
been an incredible growth
period for craft beer.
It's been double digits
for the last five years.
And when I started
Brooklyn Brewery,
people thought I was crazy.
And people tasted Brooklyn
Lager and said, my god,
it's so dark and bitter.
Why don't you make
something like Heineken?
And I said, well, Heineken
makes pretty good Heineken,
and I'm doing
something different.
But really today, everyone
knows what a craft beer is.
Back then, people didn't.
And those of us in
the first generation
and second generation
really had to educate
people in our communities and
wherever we were selling beer.
I think there are a couple
of important reasons
for the big growth
in the last decade.
One might surprise you.
It's the big
distributors in America
have suddenly embraced
craft beer in a big way.
And part of the reason why
they embraced craft beer
is because they realized
finally it's not a fad.
It's not going away.
Craft beer is now
10% of the US market.
Actually, when I
started, people said,
how are you going to compete
with the giant breweries?
And I said, well, I'm not
going to compete with them.
I'm competing with the imports.
We're making
import-quality beer,
and we're going to be competing
with the German, Belgium,
and English imports.
At that time-- 1988-- imports
were 3% of the US market.
The other 97% was
national brands.
And today, 26 years
later, imports
are 13% percent
of the US market.
Craft beer is 10%, and the
two big national brewers--
AB InBev and MillerCoors--
have been pushed back to 74%.
So actually what's
happened is better beer--
meaning imported
beer and craft beer--
have pushed into
the market share
that the big national
breweries used to have.
And one reason why is because
these distributors opened up
to craft beer.
Until about 10 years ago, the
Anheuser-Busch distributors
in America were
almost exclusively
selling Anheuser-Busch products.
August Bush III
had a policy called
100% share of mine, in which
he gave financial incentives
to distributors to only sell
Anheuser-Busch products.
And about 10 years ago, the
Anheuser-Busch distributors
saw what was happening
with craft beer
and saw the slow down in
the big national brands
and opened their doors
to craft brewers.
That chapter in the book
is called Jailbreak,
and it's about the AB
distributors saying, OK,
you can keep your
financial incentives.
We've got to get
into this category
because we're getting
killed by the MillerCoors
distributors that are
handling craft beer.
And that was a huge change.
Before that, when a
craft brewery would
go to a distributor,
a distributor
would say, OK, we'll
take this Brooklyn stuff,
but you have to sell it.
We'll deliver it.
You have to sell it.
So we would go in, basically,
to a distributor on our knees
doing a presentation, begging
them to take our beer.
Today, when we go
into a new state,
we've got the AB distributor,
the MillerCoors distributor,
probably a craft beer
distributor, and a wine
distributor begging
us to come with them,
because the large brewers
have lost an astounding
volume of beer, just
in the last five years.
They've dropped 18
million barrels of beer.
The whole craft segment is
about 16 million barrels,
so things are really
changing rapidly now.
And I think one reason
why they are changing
is because we've been
at this for 50 years,
if you go back to the
beginning with Fritz.
Another big factor
is social media.
The internet happened
at the perfect moment
for craft brewers, and a bad
moment for the big brewers.
Their domination
was really based
on controlling the media
through the three big networks.
They could talk to
everyone in America
with their beer
commercials and jingles.
All that's gone now.
The media-- I don't have to
tell you guys-- has splintered.
And you can start a
little brewery now
in the middle of
nowhere and reach
every one you want to reach
within a matter of days
for free.
And that's like a sea change
in the way beer gets marketed.
And even if you're a brewer
who doesn't know anything
about social media, the
beer enthusiasts who
write about beer and blog
about beer, they will find you,
and they will tell
the world about you.
That's another huge reason
for this big change.
Another change is our
association, the Brewers
Association.
From like the 1980s, I've been
going to the Great American
Beer Festival and the
Craft Brewers Conference.
Back in the '80s,
we were thrilled
if there were like 300 people
at the Craft Brewers Conference.
This year, the
conference in Denver,
there were between
9,000 and 10,000 people
at the conference.
I had to work to
find my friends.
And through that association
and those gatherings
every year, I've learned
so much from my colleagues
around the country.
I have friends all
over the country now
who-- I've grown up with
them in this business.
We've learned from each other,
and we've exchanged ideas.
And there's a
wonderful community
of craft brewers, which is
just an incredible advantage
for our segment.
And our brewer's association--
actually the budget now
is $20 million a year,
and we're regulated
by the federal government and
all the state governments.
So you've got to have a
strong seat at the table
to ensure that the
laws that are passed
are favorable to our segment.
The last chapters of the book
are about the next generation
of brewers-- I call them
the third generation.
And it's amazing to me-- there
are so many different business
models developing.
People starting
little breweries,
that their only
ambition is to be
the brewer in their community.
And if the laws are right, and
you can have a little tap room,
you can make a pretty
good living with something
like that.
I profile the Kodiak
Island Brewing Company
in Kodak Island, Alaska, which
is out toward the Aleutians.
I think there are more bears
on Kodiak Island than there
are people.
There are like 14,000
people I think.
But Ben Millstein and his
wife run this brewery,
and they have a tap room.
And it has become like the
social center of Kodiak Island,
and then they
couldn't be happier
with what they're doing.
There are also
gypsy brewers today,
which is people who are
passionate about beer,
have recipes for
beer, which they
get produced by
contract brewers.
There's a lot of that going
on around the country.
Craft brewers are
incredibly innovative.
There's a brewery in Texas--
you can't have a brewery
restaurant, so there
are some guys in Houston
who started a brewery called
The Eighth Wonder Brewery.
And then they
started a food truck,
and they park the food truck
in front of the brewery.
And people buy food and walk
into the brewery and buy beer.
There are also a couple of
contract breweries-- one
in Connecticut and
one in Florida--
producing beer for a lot
of the gypsy brewers.
The one in Florida
was started by guys
who were let go by
Anheuser-Busch when they got
bought by InBev a few years ago.
So it's pretty incredible
what's happening.
There are now 2,800
breweries across America.
There another 2,000
on the drawing boards,
and I think there are
going to be winners
in all different categories,
different business
models, different
styles of beer,
different focus for the
beers that are being made.
It's incredibly exciting, and
it's becoming a huge business.
And I'm very proud to
have been part of that.
Did I-- at the
beginning, did I tell you
that I used to be a
journalist and all that?
I thought I forgot that.
So I started Brooklyn
Brewery in 1987,
really-- we didn't
sell beer till '88--
but I used to be a journalist.
I started out of college.
I had a degree in English.
I tried teaching.
I almost had a
nervous breakdown.
That's the hardest thing
I ever did in my life.
And so I went to work for the
local newspaper in upstate New
York, and then I worked
for small newspapers
around New York City.
I got my big chance, a job
with the Associated Press
in Newark, New Jersey, in 1976.
And for reasons I usually go
into after I've had about four
beers, I got in my head
I wanted to cover a war.
And if you work for
AP, you can do that.
So I started studying Arabic
and said I want to go to Beirut.
And I learned there
aren't too many people who
want to go to Beirut
and cover wars,
so like a year after
I raised my hand,
I landed in Beirut as the Middle
East correspondent for AP.
That was February, 1979.
Within a few months,
I was in Iran
covering the revolution
and the hostage crisis.
For you youngsters here,
that's the movie "Argo."
And then I got kicked out
of Iran by the government.
I went back in
with the Iraqi army
when they invaded Iran in 1980.
I covered that war
from the Iraqi side.
I lived in Beirut, which was
crazy with the civil war going
on.
Actually I was abducted
with the UN patrol
in South Lebanon in 1980.
Very nasty incident.
Two of the guys with me--
Irish UN peacekeepers--
were tortured and killed, and
one guy was shot five times.
I carried him out, and he lived.
Actually, I bet you
all know Vice Media.
Yeah, of course, right?
Course you do.
People over 30 don't know
anything about Vice Media.
Vice Media is actually based
right across the street
from the brewery in
Brooklyn, and I just
recently wrote a story
for them in January,
because about a year ago
Homeland Security contacted me.
And they said the guy
who abducted me in 1980
is living in Detroit
running an ice cream truck.
He's the Good Humor man.
So I said, you're kidding.
And they said he's applied
for US citizenship,
and they want me to
testify against him.
And I said absolutely.
And it's a long story.
Take a look at it.
It's on Vice.
Click the magazine
and put my name in,
and you'll find the story.
But I haven't had
to testify yet,
so I don't know what's
going to happen.
You'll see it's a
complicated story.
Actually, Rupert Murdoch
invested $70 million
in Vice for 5%.
It's really remarkable.
And the guys at Vice
told me that Google
is about to do the
same thing, but I
don't know if anyone
knows anything about that.
Google is buying
everything I think.
So that was my background.
I covered the Israeli
invasion, the massacres
in the refugee camps.
I moved to Cairo.
I was sitting behind
President Sadat
when he was killed
at the parade.
So this was all great training
for starting a brewery
in Brooklyn and for
eventually writing
a couple books, one
about Brooklyn Brewery
and one about the
craft beer revolution.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
I'm surprised there
aren't more women here.
I always say that at
events at the brewery,
we get half women and half men.
Maybe it's Monday, and
the beer, I don't know.
But it's good to see the women.
And thank you all
for coming out,
and I'm happy to
answer some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
CALEB: So if you
guys have questions,
I'm going to ask
you to use the mic.
AUDIENCE: What's your take
on craft brewers selling out
to larger distributors,
for instance, Goose Island.
STEVE HINDY: Selling
out to big brewers.
Yeah.
I think it's kind of inevitable.
I mean, Goose Island--
actually, just last week I
did an event in Chicago with
John Hall, the founder of Goose
Island.
John is-- he was 70 years
old when he sold out.
His son wasn't interested
in staying in the company.
So what are you going to do?
John's my friend.
I accept it, but
Goose Island is now
totally controlled
by Anheuser-Busch.
And that makes them the
enemy, to put it bluntly.
CALEB: I have a
question for you, Steve.
You said there were about 2,800
breweries in operation now
and about 2,000 on
the drawing board.
Does that seem like
we're going to fill up,
like this is almost
too many breweries.
It's hard to imagine
almost 2/3 more than now
and still having
space for everyone.
STEVE HINDY: Yeah,
good question.
I don't think so.
The way the segment
is growing, I
think we're behind in
keeping up with the demand.
And before prohibition,
there were 2,000 breweries
in America, and the population
was about 40 or 50 million.
Today there are 325
million people in America.
I think we can handle
5,000 breweries.
So I don't think
that's a problem.
The problem is
going to be-- we've
been-- you know
this word, but we've
been very disruptive to
the American beer industry.
We butted heads
with the big guys.
We butted heads with
the distributors.
There are laws in place that
are very unfavorable to us.
We're going to be butting
heads with the distributors
and the big guys
on a lot of issues.
And I'm excited about that.
I think it's going to be great
fun, but it is disruptive.
And there's going to be
more disruption I believe.
AUDIENCE: I notice
that you started
to distribute Brooklyn
Brewery beer internationally.
I was wondering if you have
a specific strategy for how
you want to start
exporting it, because I'm
sure that there's a lot of
different ways it can go.
And also if you feel like
it's helpful to leverage
how popular Brooklyn even
has become as a brand,
because I feel like it has
international recognition
at this point too.
STEVE HINDY: Yeah,
great question.
We're in New York City,
so a lot of foreigners
come to New York City,
tourist and business people,
and we've had opportunities to
export from the very beginning.
Actually, we started selling
beer in Japan in our first--
in 1988, our first
year in business.
And we didn't have a strategy.
But our rule was, if
you want us to ship you
beer in Tokyo or London or
Australia, you pay us first,
and then we'll ship the beer.
It was pretty simple.
And over the years, we've
gotten better and better quality
importers to bring our beer
into different markets.
Our partner right
now in Scandinavia
is Carlsberg, the number
four brewer in the world.
And actually we just opened
a brewery in Stockholm
called the New Carnegie
Brewery with Carlsberg.
And please go to
visit if you're there.
It's really cool.
And we operate the brewery.
We have a subsidiary
called Brooklyn Sweden.
We hired the brewers.
We hired the chef.
And it's right on the water.
There's a free ferry
that goes to it.
And we're going to be announcing
a project like that in Asia
in the next week or 10 days.
And I think we're going to
have a lot of opportunities
to export.
About 30% of our
production, which
was 220,000 barrels last
year-- about 30% is export.
And I think in the
next decade, exports
are going to be at
least 50% of our sales.
We sell in 26
states, and because
of this export business,
which is good solid business--
we don't discount to export.
We make good margin on that.
For that reason, we're
growing at like 25%,
and we see no hurry to try
to come to the West Coast
because of the good fortune
we're having heading east.
And anyway all the
west coast brewers
are already in the East
Coast, as you may know
and now building breweries
in the East Coast.
Yes, the name Brooklyn
has been amazing for us.
And it's funny, because when
I started a lot of people
questioned naming
the beer Brooklyn.
They said, geesh, the image is
not so great, including people
who-- like lifelong
Brooklyners questioned it.
I said, no, I think
Brooklyn is a great name.
So many immigrants
go through here,
and people have connections--
weird connections to Brooklyn.
Now there are like 100
companies in Brooklyn
that have consumer products
with the name Brooklyn.
Actually, I got to give a
lot of credit for that name
to my designer Milton Glaser.
He's the guy who did the
I Love New York logo.
Actually, they
call him the father
of American graphic design.
Milton's an amazing guy.
In the beginning, I wanted to
call the beer Brooklyn Eagle
Beer, after the old
Brooklyn Eagle newspaper,
edited by Walt Whitman, because
I used to be a newspaper man.
And in my first
meeting with Milton,
I told him what I
wanted to call it,
and I told him I want
the Brooklyn Bridge,
and I want the Dodgers,
and I want all this stuff.
And he said, well look,
we got Brooklyn here.
Forget the eagle.
Who needs an eagle
when you got Brooklyn?
Call it Brooklyn Beer.
It fits.
Brooklyn fits with beer.
And he came up with our iconic
B logo, which-- it's brilliant.
I have to admit, the first
time I saw it, I looked at it
and said, is that it?
And Milton said, look,
don't say a word.
Take it home, put on
your kitchen table,
show it to your wife.
Don't show it to a lot of
people-- just live with it.
And I did that,
and it sunk in this
is a beautiful, simple image
and a great image for a brewery.
So we love Brooklyn.
And the Nets won yesterday.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this is sort of the
flip side of that same question
about drinking locally.
I mean, we've seen the rise
of the local food movement
over this same
period, and I guess
the question is, does local
beer go with local food?
I haven't seen that always
connected necessarily,
but is that part of
the movement or not?
STEVE HINDY: It definitely
is part of what's going on.
I think it's part
of what's happening
in a lot of food categories.
But with beer, people want
to try different things.
And so we sell most of
our beer in New York City.
Actually, our second
biggest market
is Sweden, if you
can believe that.
It's a little bigger
than New Jersey for us.
And I feel that we
have some unique beers.
Actually the two you're tasting
today-- Brooklyn Sorachi Ace is
made with a hop that was
developed in northern Japan,
now grown in Washington state.
Anything but local,
but it's a beer
that is very special for us.
Actually, we're coming out
with a low alcohol version
of that called Brooklyn
1/2 Ale later this year.
So, yeah, part of
it is about local,
but it's also about
exploring different beers
from different places.
And so I think there's
a place for both.
Actually, it's very difficult
to do a strictly local beer.
We have one beer called
Brooklyn Green Market Wheat
Beer, that we do with the
not-for-profit that runs the 53
farmers markets
in New York City.
And that beer is made
with 100% grain grown
within like 200 miles
of New York City.
70% in New York state
and the other 30%
I think in Massachusetts.
But it's very limited because
the production of grain
is very limited.
So if you look at people
who are touting local,
often you'll find
their ingredients
are coming from
all over the world.
So it'll be awhile
before I think
strictly local
beers are available.
And we will be making one
when they are available.
I can assure you.
AUDIENCE: When the tables
turned on your conversation
with the bigger
distributors, and they're
knocking at your door
instead of vice versa,
did that change your strategy
on how you ran the brewery,
how you brewed different beers?
Did you take bigger chances,
knowing that you have this
in into these other
distribution paths and channels?
STEVE HINDY: Did it
change our strategy?
Well, it certainly
increased our sales
when the big
wholesalers opened up.
We were a little more confident.
We just did like a $12
million expansion in Brooklyn,
and knowing that we had first
rate wholesalers handling
our beer made that a much
more comfortable decision.
Our best selling beer is still
our first beer, Brooklyn Lager.
It's about 50-- over
50% of our sales.
The other 50% is a whole
range of different beers,
the special kind of
beers you have here,
regular seasonal beers like
Oktoberfest Pumpkin Ale, Summer
Ale, and that kind of thing.
But part of the challenge
in managing distributors
now is teaching them to handle
a very complex portfolio.
Practically every
craft brewery now
has a very complex
portfolio of brands,
and the game is learning
how to present those
to the distributor
and get into the minds
of their sales people.
AUDIENCE: Do you want
to tell us something
about the beers that
we're [INAUDIBLE]?
STEVE HINDY: Yeah.
The Sorachi Ace is a
saison-style, a Belgian style.
Our brewmaster,
Garrett Oliver, who's
written a couple a
great books, one called
"The Brewmaster's Table,"
and Garrett is also
the Editor-In-Chief of the
"Oxford Companion to Beer,"
which is the first ever
encyclopedia of beer,
published by Oxford
University Press.
When Garrett first tried
the Sorachi Ace hop,
he immediately in
his head said, I
got to make a saison
using this hop.
And we first made it as
a brewmasters reserve,
which is a-- every quarter we
come up with a new draft beer.
And then customers
subscribe to that program.
So Sorachi Ace was a draft
beer like three years ago,
and it was incredibly popular.
So we came out with this
bottle-conditioned version
of it in the 750.
And later this
year, we'll come out
with a 12 ounce version
of that in a four pack.
The other beer is
part of a series
we do quarterly called the
Brooklyn Quarterly Experiment,
and those are barrel-aged beers.
So that other beer, I believe,
is a version of our Local 2,
which is like a Belgian double.
And it's got some
orange peel in it,
and it's been aged
in bourbon barrels
with a brettanomyces
yeast, which
is a wild yeast that gives
you kind of funky flavors.
But it's not over the top
with the funky flavors.
It's pretty subtle.
Actually, that beer is
fantastic with a lot of foods.
And so is Sorachi
for that matter.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could go over
the style of IPAs.
They kind of epitomize
what craft beer
is to a lot of people.
And then Brooklyn Brewery's
relationship with hops.
STEVE HINDY: Well, yeah,
IPA is the bestselling style
of craft beer now, and
the west coast brewers
are crazy about hops.
I think west coast people, a lot
of them are crazy about hops.
East coast, I mean,
Brooklyn Brewery,
we're a little
more about balance.
We're not particularly looking
to blow your brains out
with the hops.
I think Vinnie Cilurzo
at Russian River
was the first guy
to do a double IPA.
I think a lot of people
credited him with that.
And that's part of the beauty
of the craft beer revolution,
is the different kind of
regional styles of beers.
We do have an IPA called
Brooklyn East India Pale
Ale, which Garrett, our
brewmaster, developed in 1994.
And it's actually
extremely balanced.
It doesn't come anywhere
near to competing in the blow
your brains out hop category.
We have a beer called Brooklyn
Blast, which is a double IPA,
and also is pretty balanced
compared to West Coast.
But, you know,
vive la difference.
AUDIENCE: I recently
became aware
of Dogfish Head's Ancient
Ale Wine doing crazy things
like resurrecting Nordic grog.
Are there other
examples of brewers
doing crazy unique
things like this?
STEVE HINDY: Yeah, I think
there are a lot of examples.
I did this reddit "ask me
anything" thing the other day.
I responded to 146
people in two hours.
And my favorite call-- or
email-- was from Brazil.
And they asked me if I had
tried the new ant beer.
I said, you mean
it has ants in it?
And he said, yeah.
And I said, no, I haven't.
But I got to tell you,
it gives me the creeps.
We've talked about--
I'd like to do--
the world's foremost
Egyptologist, Dr. Kent Weeks,
is a friend of mine.
I got to know him when I
lived in Egypt years ago,
and I've always wanted to do
a beer based on the recipes
that they've found in
tombs in Egypt with Kent.
But so far we haven't
been able to do that.
There's also an interesting
beer that Rogue has,
which this also
gives me the creeps.
The yeast in that
beer is cultured
from the brewmaster
John Mayer's beard.
Doesn't that sound appetizing?
I doubt that's going to
set the world on fire.
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
the distributor relationship
that you were
describing earlier.
As you said, the AB and
other guys' distributors
are now willing to
take your stuff,
and when you go into a
new state with reputation
like Brooklyn has,
it makes sense
that they're asking
you to come to them.
What have you seen-- how
has that relationship gone
for smaller
breweries that you've
seen starting up more recently?
Is there an in with
the distributors?
Does the three-tier system end
up hurting smaller breweries?
What do you see in that?
STEVE HINDY: The
three-tier system--
a feature of the three-tier
system is the franchise law.
The franchise law
has been in the news
lately because of
Elon Musk trying
to sell his Teslas
direct to consumers,
and some states saying no, you
can't do that in our state.
You have to go through a dealer.
So that's what a
franchise law is.
In the beer business,
the distributor
essentially owns your
brand, in most states.
When you give it
to a distributor,
it's a captive brand.
You can't get it back, unless
you can prove bad faith dealing
on their part, which is
very difficult to prove.
I understand why
that law is in place.
It really keeps the distributors
independent of the big brewers
coming in and essentially
strong arming them
into selling only the
big distributors' beers.
But it's very unfair, I
believe, for small brewers,
because if you get
with a distributor--
say you sign on with
a distributor who's
a startup craft beer
distributor, or a wine
distributor.
And you grow to a certain
level, and they can't really
take you beyond that.
But you know you
could go beyond that.
So it makes it very difficult
to go to a bigger distributor,
to change distributors.
In New York, we got a
law passed that says
if you're under 3% of the
distributor's business,
and you're under 300,000
barrels in production,
you can move to a
different distributor.
You have to pay-- you have
to compensate the distributor
before you leave, but
most new distributors
will pay for that kind of deal.
So that's called a carve
out of these franchise laws,
and I'm hoping we're
going to be able to get
that in other states.
I think it makes the
system much more fair.
I'm not against franchise laws.
I just think for the
smallest brewers,
you can end up in jail.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE HINDY: The distributor
takes you on and sits on you
so his competitor can't get
you, and that's not fair.
AUDIENCE: So do you feel that
the macro-brewers are getting
any more successful at
breaking into the craft beer
market with the crafty beers.
STEVE HINDY: There's an
index in the back of my book
in which I tried to do a
chronology of big brewer
efforts to play in our category.
And I think it's really
only in the last five years
that they've come to believe
that this thing is real.
It's not going away.
But they've been fiddling around
with it since the mid-'80s.
I think it's a compliment
to us that they're
playing in our segment.
MillerCoors has Blue Moon.
AB has Shock Top
and Goose Island.
They just bought
Blue Point Brewery,
which is on Long Island,
New York, near Brooklyn.
So they're playing
in the category.
It's a compliment.
It's a challenge to us.
I think it's a real
dilemma for them,
because the more they introduce
people to flavorful beer--
if a person is drinking
a Blue Moon tonight,
craft beer drinkers
are very-- actually I
don't like this word.
The big guys call
them promiscuous.
They're not brand-loyal.
They want to try new things.
And I think if they're
drinking a Shock Top or a Blue
Moon or a Goose
Island, they are more
likely to drink a Brooklyn
Lager or one of our beers.
So I think it's a very
tricky game for the big guys,
because the more
they promote flavor,
the more they undercut
their big brands, which
are not about flavor.
They were about power marketing.
And that game has
all changed now
with the splintering
of the media
and the internet, et cetera.
So we'll see what happens.
Craft beer is like 10%
by volume, about 15,
16% by dollars.
I think it's going to be 30%
maybe in the next 20 years.
And when I say
craft beer, I'm only
saying based on the Brewer's
Association definition.
If you add in the crafty beers,
it gets up above, close to 20%
already.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]